[Music]
rafie Mendelson welcome to 20 minute
leaders and now talking about Israel at
War a startup Nation United thank you so
much for being a part of this uh first
of all a part of the of the effort that
we have collectively what you're doing
with Cabra is hugely impactful a i
reading over the statistics and what
you've been doing over the last I guess
eight days or so is remarkable
and you know let's start tell me a
little bit about you know a little bit
about Cabra and a little bit about what
is Cabra doing before out of context
with the war that's going on sure so
thanks for having us on Mike I really
appreciate the opportunity to talk
through this CRA as a company we work
with governments and also large
multinational corporations around the
world um to be able to monitor social
media and to identify threats so we work
firmly in the disinformation space uh
fighting disinformation fighting fake
accounts and we have been for the last 5
years so you for example when Russia
invaded Ukraine we were really in depth
looking at Russian bot networks we're at
the moment analyzing the US 2024
election campaign and uncovering
multiple bot networks consisting of
thousands of different fake accounts and
looking at the way that malicious actors
spread their disinformation and looking
to conduct their influence campaigns so
as a platform the platform we built you
can think of it as a social media search
engine where we scan conversations and
we have kind of unique technology to be
able to identify fake accounts um and
that's kind of the the area that we work
in that we know really well so after
October the 7th when everything kicked
off um we leapt straight into what we
know best uh and that is scanning the
conversations and seeing what
intelligence we can learn from the
enemies activity taking place online and
actually what we found was was you know
shocking and and almost unbelievable
okay so let let's dive into it and I see
Ben gion is a is in a portrait right
right back there I believe next to Abby
Road um what did what did you discover
what you know it's been eight days into
the War I believe what what did you
discover now um looking back so what we
discovered is a a whole lot of fake
accounts uh over 40,000 of them 40,000
fake pramas accounts across the main
social media platforms and in fact many
of them had been created a year year and
a half in advance uh and that gives us
an indication of the kind of planning
and scale you know before we even
analyze what those accounts are doing we
can see the scale that's taking place
you much of the conversation at the
moment is taking place is talking about
how the scale and the planning that went
into the ground Invasion and how
shocking it was but actually you
attribute you attribute the fact that
these 40,000 accounts were created a
year ago you believe that that in part
was a leadup to this to this October 7th
surprise attack yeah absolutely and so
that's a common tactic with
disinformation campaigns is fake
accounts being created in advance many
of them not all 40,000 of them were
created a year and a half ago many of
them were created well in advance and
we're pretty much not doing not doing a
lot right we're kind of line dormant
waiting it's almost like an online
Soldier waiting to be put into the
online Battleground yeah and they
weren't doing much but then when it came
to October the 7th over the course of
the first 48 Hours some of these
accounts were posting over 600 times
posting out you know and pushing fake
narratives so again it's just when we
look at the social media conversations
there's a lot of conversations online
and all of us in Israel outside of
Israel are drawn towards social media to
get our real time instant information
that's what people around the world
doing that's what a lot of journalists
are doing that I'm speaking to at the
moment but what cyber is particularly
focused on and what we do and trying
uncovering the activities of malicious
actors is by uncovering fake accounts
and then tracking the kind of activities
that they're doing and that gives us a
lot of information so seeing the scale
number one and then seeing number two
what are the kinds of things these
accounts are doing and the kinds of
narratives that they're pushing out
right okay so so walk me through the
it's the morning of October 7th what's
going on with Cabra as a company so
you're obviously you make a dramatic you
shift a focus and you take sort of a
spotlight into this specific area walk
me through sort of the company formation
communication that took place during
that morning absolutely so a big chunk
of the company went immediately into
milim and we called up and went into
milim uh and then a lot of those who
hadn't been called up into the reserve
duty um immediately sprung to action and
used the platform that we had built
without being asked without without
anyone asking us to do so you know we we
we know what we know uh and we've
developed the platform in order to be
able to uncover these kinds of things in
exactly these kinds of situations uh and
so we started running scans on the
conversations that were taking place
using you know Hebrew Search terms
English Search terms Arabic Search terms
and then being able to uncover just a
sheer scale of the conversation in order
to be able to pinpoint those fake
accounts okay and and who how is this
integrated into the larger ecosystem so
Cabra is is a identifying a lot of these
fake accounts and you're you're doing
more things beyond that how is this
integrated into the United United
Battlefront that Israel is now fighting
absolutely so we have many of our
colleagues who are working with other
organizations uh and other similar types
of companies to be able to scan whether
it's social media on our side whether
it's you know deep in dark web on the
other side and looking at all of the
different sources where we can glean
information intelligence from and then
using our Technologies and other
Technologies to be able to come together
we've shared one part is being able to
share that information with the
intelligence units there's some stuff
that we can't go into detail um but then
there's a whole other side which is the
public facing side I suppose you can
think of which is much of what we've
talked about today which is really
explaining to everybody and explaining
to the world that what we're seeing here
isn't a group of
disorganized uh you know militants you
know this is or terrorists this is a
highly sophisticated well planned well
organized in advance um resourced uh uh
organization it's akin to a state level
actor uh level of organization and being
able to help spread that word and and
let people know that just like on the
ground we saw lots of evidence that this
was months if not years in the planning
so too in the online space and kind of
spreading the world the word that what
we're seeing here is an online
Battleground that's taking place as well
what is the sense internally around what
you doing so you're putting in a lot of
this effort you you've been focused a
lot you mentioned on you know Russia
Ukraine you mentioned us elections
there's I'm sure there's employees that
are connected to the US and Russia and
Ukraine but but naturally these are
things that are more external now we're
dealing with things in our own backyard
how is this change the sort of the
feeling or the energy around the way
that you're operating as a company well
I think that's definitely the word
energy you know the energy that's being
put into uh what we are trying to
uncover the work that my colleagues have
been putting into day and night not
stopping until they're able to uncover
the scale of what we've been able to see
and there's a lot of information you can
study and learn from uh looking at the
behaviors of these fake accounts looking
at the way that they are sophisticated
looking at the way that they are
coordinated and looking actually one of
the key things that we've uncovered is
how in real time they are pushing out
false narratives so sometimes when we
think of disinformation we think of
previously prepared preped fake
information fake news fake content
that's actually not what we saw here we
saw uh video content that was taken from
the day and in real time that was you
know taken a short clip of it or uh
edited and then
recontextualized in order to be able to
add to that a false narrative and then
distributed by thousands of fake
accounts that tells us a lot of
information tells us of the scale of the
activities that has gone into trying to
change the narratives and also uh it
tells us it showed us almost immediately
that one in four accounts on social
media related to this event the
discussion about Israel and versus Hamas
online was a fake account and so once we
know that and once we are able to tell
people that that actually it's one in
four accounts that we saw over the first
couple of days on the 7th and 8th of
October that involves a huge amount of
work in order to be able to uncover that
uh and uh a lot of work by my colleagues
to be able to do that and and you know
cudos to them and they've done
incredible work to be able to uncover
that aspect of the the battle that we're
fighting incredible Rafi thank you for
everything you guys are doing thank you
for putting all the all the energy tuned
into this I think it's a I've been
following closely H the work that
sabra's been doing since obviously
understanding that you know um being
good friends with Dan and with Sabra as
a company understanding the context that
you're living in and how relevant this
is into this Warfare where I've been
talking about how you know there's one
Battlefield that's happening which is
the the terrible terrible Battlefield
where the blood is being shed by our
brothers and sisters out in the field
and and then there's another War
happening which is the public discourse
War it's a war that's happening here you
know around the world in the US or you
know in Europe that the way that people
are discussing we're seeing that this
active conversation and this is a global
fight on terrorism it's not just Israel
versus Kamas this is Israel is now as a
as a guiding I think champ CH against
Global terrorism and and that's why the
whole world needs to care about this
thank you very much for all the work
that you're doing and for articulating
it so well and uh continue making a
positive impact for all of us thank you
thank you very much for time and if
anyone wants to follow the CRA account
online and also Dan bramy we're putting
out more information as we find it and
also as well it's we are a platform we
work with governments and and businesses
but we've also been putting out
information about how individuals can
approach social media how they can be
more assured of what they're reading is
actually true of the profiles that
they're engaging with is actually real
so people should feel free to uh to
follow that stuff and and also get in
touch if they have any questions awesome
thank
[Laughter]
you